regardez meilleur pour la fin cyril paie
quoi sert il vous êtes un grand
animateur tout le monde le sait a
commenté ray beaucoup de talent quand tu
commences comme ça c'est pas du tout
vous avez la vanne facile vous avez une
répartie exceptionnel et ça vous ne le
faisais pas de nulle part
cette semaine encore on a eu du très
grand cyril alors on connaît la cash
machine lancement ringard voici tout de
suite la casse machine
j'ai envie de prendre ton cul pour une
trousse alors c'est parce que vous avez
ce soir qu'est ce que j'ai dit au sujet
de la clean qu'est ce que j'ai dis
jamais tu lis mais ils me disent on va
l'augmenter tout cas vous risquez pas
d'être augmentée casta caste à la loeb
ce casque à casque à lalobbe sensu c'est
effectivement comme l'a dit guillaume ça
n'a absolument pas bougé d'un iota par
rapport au niveau habituel où vous
appelle dans deux minutes
allez chercher vos dalmatiens il vous
revient dans deux minutes deux minutes
c'est un cap et là je pense qu'on sera
bien marché pour la merde que c'est
c'est mon premier producteur de télé
mais j'ai jamais rien fait et les
audiences a pas particulièrement hier
soir oui barbe à papa et ma bulle
toi tu dois avoir un bagout machine avec
l'oseille que tu le prends depuis 15 ans
sur la vie de ma mère
entre rtl et ici on te paye quand même
même si tu ne manques pas frères toit
sur la tête de ma mère chaude doit dire
à mon robe de deken pourra voir
l'héritage après
vous savez pas des zinfonautes c'est
sympa
[Rires]